so the vmas aired on mtv on sunday night
i know what you're thinking wait the
vmas are still the thing and i know what
else you're thinking wait mtv is still a
thing i was just as surprised as you on
both counts i only know that this event
occurred last night because i read
through dozens of news articles every
morning as part of my job
and in my scavenging i stumbled across a
few articles
listing the winners of the
2021 vmas if you're curious and you
probably aren't the winner for video of
the year was montero by lil nas x
the one where he he twerks on satan
mtv giving its highest award to a video
where a gay man dry hump satan is
probably the least surprising
development of the year justin bieber
won artist of the year his 27th straight
win in that category i assume the trophy
for best collaboration went to doja cat
featuring
scizza
sza i have no idea who those people are
or even how many people they are but
apparently one of them came on stage
dressed like some kind of
nightmarish sea cucumber so that was
interesting
but the most shocking thing there there
there she is
that is uh that's dojika is that dojika
or sizza i don't know
looks like maybe uh maybe one of those
worms from the movie tremors
well the most shocking thing about that
outfit is that it covers more than three
percent of her body
many of the
other celebrities i'm assuming doja cat
is a celebrity decided to show up and
see through outfits thongs and so on and
so on um the performances on stage were
in keeping with that theme a woman named
chloe writhed around on stage twerking
uh slapping her butt in front of a giant
blinking sign that said booty so big
now that was downright subtle in
comparison to
somebody named normani who sang her hit
song wild side i'm assuming it's a hit
song while rubbing herself against
another woman who was strapped to a
bondage board meanwhile lil nazex
strutted the red carpet doing some
crossdressing
some sort of pant suit slash dress
combination and there was no shortage of
of politics to punctuate the debauchery
sydney lopper who evidently is still
alive
took to the stage to present an award
and then rant about abortion rights
and speaking of the elderly community
madonna was also on the scene she walked
onto the stage wearing a giant coat
and then dramatically uh stripped the
coat off to reveal the skimpy leather
dominatrix outfit and thong underneath
i'm not going to show you the thong part
i'll i'll have some mercy on you but
there's there's the outfit
now this is when you know that it's time
to put nana in a home
you can make the argument that even
allowing her to wander on stage looking
like that is a form of elder abuse
she even looks kind of you see there in
the in especially in the picture on the
right she looks kind of dazed and
confused
she doesn't know where she is
she has that sort of uncertain facial
expression that joe biden has made
famous we can only pray that biden
doesn't ever appear in front of cameras
dressed in a similar way
but at this point anything is possible
and now i've just pictured
biden in that outfit in my head and i
want to cry and yet in a certain way
i'm glad that madonna showed up and
stripped off her clothes
because
there's something sort of profound and
emblematic about it
here she is an old woman
having long since run out of things to
say
and ways to shock and offend
reduced to simply
stripping on camera in her
late 90s
begging for our attention
it's not offensive so much as sad and
pitiful dull
you don't want to yell at her about it
you want to give her a coat and a bowl
of soup and pat her on the head and say
it's okay you don't have to do this
anymore
grandma sit down you'll be all right
let's put let's let's just watch some tv
murder she wrote is on i think
now madonna in that way is a good
representative of the whole event and of
the broader pop culture that she helped
to create
there was last night plenty of
debauchery and perversion and nudity and
all kinds of desperate sexual attention
seeking and none of it managed to make
any waves at all
the vmas ratings have been collapsing
for years nobody cares
you only know about any of this because
i'm telling you and i only i only know
about it because i read a couple of
articles just so that i can make the
point that i'm making right now
madonna was relevant back during a time
when
pop artists could simply wear revealing
outfits and sing about sex and um that
was enough to create controversy and
uh drive
publicity you know she could
roll around on stage in a wedding outfit
singing about losing her virginity
that was a big moment that was
revolutionary wow
but now pop stars can hump each other in
bondage gear while singing graphically
about their genitals and it goes
unnoticed
they have to go to greater and greater
extremes to generate the sort of hype
that madonna could once attract with a
fraction of the effort
you know lil nasek speaking of him got
some of the attention that he hopelessly
yearns for when he made that twerking
satan video but that controversy died
down pretty quickly and everybody moved
on and that's why he has to dream up new
degeneracies every week just to stay
within the vicinity of the limelight
last week he was
posing for pictures
while wearing a fake pregnancy baby bump
and uh and that was supposed to be
a thing
but even that's pretty boring and
standard these days especially in a
culture where millions of people
actually believe that men can literally
get pregnant
there was a time when it was considered
revolutionary and rebellious to be a
vile vulgar pervert
the perverts were rebelling against a
culture that rightly disapproved of that
behavior they were seeking to tear down
moral standards and structures that they
claimed were oppressive and restricting
and they succeeded
the perverts won
but the thing about staging a revolution
and winning
is that now you are the man you're the
system you're the very institution of
power that you once sought to destroy
so you stage the revolution and you win
now you have to take over and run these
things that you were just five seconds
ago trying to tear down
so now the vulgar perverts aren't
rebelling against anything at all
madonna is old enough to be the
grandmother of most of the rest of the
people she shared the stage with
that means that as they were bumping and
grinding and showing their asses and
shouting look at me look at me
they were behaving exactly as a woman
their grandmother's age once behaved and
still does
there's nothing revolutionary or
shocking about it it's mainstream it's
acceptable
it's boring
it's empty it's feeble it's pathetic
of course this kind of stuff has always
been empty feeble and pathetic it was
empty feeble pathetic back when madonna
was doing it 30 years ago and everybody
thought it was revolutionary
but decades ago people made the mistake
of thinking that artists quote unquote
who showed their butts and sang about
sex were doing something brilliant and
and significant simply because it was
rebellious
now that it's no longer rebellious the
shine has worn off and it's easy to look
at it and think wow these people really
just have nothing at all to say
i'm bored what else is on
this is perhaps the most underrated
aspect of living in a morally decayed
culture
because if you didn't know any better
and you weren't living in such a culture
and you thought about it you might think
well
that could be fun at least
that's not it's quite boring
i mean it's many other things as well
but it's certainly boring
as it turns out evil has a rather bland
flavor
now the good news is that amid all this
dull hollow decadence
virtue becomes exciting and rebellious
i mean pop stars can spread their legs
and take off their clothes and scream
about their right to kill babies and
none of that is remotely revolutionary
or brave but if one of them had appeared
on stage to speak in defense of the
unborn or to promote chastity and
modesty
or even to defend something like
patriotism
that would have been truly shocking
and required real courage
it would have been a revolutionary act
none of them have the spine for that or
the value system so it didn't happen yet
the fact remains that the moral code
these people fight against
is the moral code of today's true
cultural revolutionaries we are now
the guerrilla warriors fighting against
powerful institutions who despise us and
seek to destroy and oppress us
it's not a good situation to be in i
would
not prefer it if i was given the choice
but it does provide an opportunity to
connect with people especially young
people who naturally desire to rebel
against systems of power
so we can say to them join us that's our
side
the rebels we're the rebels
[Music]
or you can join the naked grandma on
stage to defend
the boring status quo
well i hope you enjoyed that clip for
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content